et bien bonjour les amis bienvenue dans
cette deuxième vidéo au canada cette
fois on n'est plus du tout à montréal on
est à ottawa éléments arrivent en
marchant vers mac et 6 masse le monde
assure que le micro mais les gens
demandant de bien t'en fais pas je sais
faire au match et que la marque est ce
qui a marqué ici vous savez tout cela il
ya marqué parc oméga re c'est 800
hectares d'habitat naturel
on va se balader au milieu des animaux
en voiture on va dormir dans un tipi
traditionnel c'est où j'ai toujours
voulu faire ça je vous propose qu'on y
avait tout de suite partout mes gars
c'est parti jour 2 au canada
[Musique]
bonjour messieurs aux jo comment
fera-t-il que oui andré andrieu jantes
et andré bonjour janvier serge enchanté
vous êtes au guide we dance vous filâtre
espérance de vie est de 2 minutes
apparemment dites nous qui vous êtes
vous tout savoir alors serge dossier je
fais directeur technique et porte parole
du parc oméga et moi c'est andres un
jour je suis agent communication chez
tourisme outaouais
donc tu fréquentes un peu moins les
animaux juifs en moto passion née en
août à royan ne placer les rebelles je
traiterai la région ils nous avaient
prévu un petit programme
oui apparemment caisse quoi faire ce
soir le parc comme un gosse et la
découverte de la nature canadienne de sa
faune vrai de son histoire et de
l'esprit des 11 premières nations du
québec
alors ce soir on va faire face à face
avec une meute de loups
je les aime déjà à la sq on peut dire
que ça je ressemble à chris pratt dans
jurassic board montrant cette voiture et
voyons des animaux c'est parti on est on
est choqué
ouais
hop et on vote contre les jets avec la
super massifs tels que je nourris du
parc un wapiti balle typique elle a
essayé de trouver un mal avec des gains
pana qu on voit la faune m
elle est tellement triste on ouvre mon
gars c'est une super belle 40 côté de
toi allez hop
il a compris comme une carotte avec a
pas compris la nature
maintenant ces premières convoitées toi
tu en as besoin d'un bon gars et dope sa
passe combien on va tipi faut pas
l'énerver du tout quoi on est tombé sur
un ours tout va bien on va tenter
versez le vin dans sa lettre
allez viens allez hop ok il s'en bat les
couilles à les tâches de l'emi dessus et
moi on va pas revu tous ces animaux et
leur avoir donné les carottes on change
le véhicule et on passe sur un séquestre
est né avec moi tu nous as mais
nouveauté tient à la main ou typique et
on peut y aller qu'est que ce véhicule
absolument ohlala j'ai l'impression est
à jurassic park mich de jure
[Musique]
on arrive aux types et les glaires on va
dormir là dedans
êtes vous on va dormir aux abricots y va
se faire à feu on va boire des bières on
va faire un bon délire entre amis avec
serge qui va nous raconter plein de
belles histoires sur avant d'aller voir
les loups la dompter un t-rex une fois
je crois serge ab-so-lu-ment à deux on
est prêt à voir avec les mots honneur à
toi vas-y tu remplaces clément sans bon
sens le bois de ouf
mais t'as vu comme ses hôtes ont bien et
même des ours sur des couvertures on vit
le délire à s'en servir
tu vas toucher ou drive tu touches où
vous pourrez dire adieu aux 8ièmes
pêcheurs locaux sont superbes
ce sont le bois sentez-vous mec c'est
fou
[Musique]
ok ans en france actuellement dans les
bois pour rencontrer les loups et let go
on te suit rennes toi voilà des lots ils
sont juste à côté et lui c'est le malade
pointé juste ici le chef de la meute
[Musique]
les amis serge nous invite à nourrir les
loups on va nous faire déjouer avec
c'est juste fou voilà donc on fait ça
égaie haribo ça marche jamais quand ils
ont clairement ça dans le sang allez
allez cfoot j'adopte c'est parti je
repars avec serge vient d'expliquer que
c'est que le mâle alpha qui hurlent en
premier et ensuite les autres vont
suivre
messi lui il hurle pas les autres vont
pas pouvoir hurler et en fait t'es quand
il ya une mode qui est petit par exemple
assez une note de 13
mais comme ils sont par exemple 6 eh ben
le mâle alpha va pas trop sûrs les
patrons ferment mal hein parce que les
modes sont capables de compter combien
il ya de loups dans l'autre note pour
doser la puissance d'une mode quoi c'est
assez fou et du coup la vie qui sont 13
ils ont souvent cette nuit on risque de
se réveiller parce qu'il criait ouvrir
l'école
c'est fou des vrais loups se sera pas
serge comme la ce a vraiment des books
ou alors voilà près de vingt ans d'un
cri on sortira on verra si serge mille
merci pour cette expérience de malade
mais c'est un un gain plaisir de vous
faire découvrir cette belle nature elle
confiera et à partager à 200% voit les
rssi g20 à cannes avait à la gare
plaisir est trop sympa avec réduit
repose toi bien
demain on veut qu'ils soient en forme à
demain à berlin
[Musique]
ça mais je me fait réveiller par le
critt loup ça fout
ou alors c'est serge sais pas si
puissant
les amis on a dû quitter cers écrite
c'était triste maintenant le faire je
sais qu'il ya cette vidéo merci pour
tout ce que tu nous a offert tu t'es
dingue mais aujourd'hui deuxième jour en
outaouais à ottawa par dong outaouais
bien sûr je prenais outaouais on va
faire du rafting toute la journée savez
tous ont pu s'y fait hyper beau on est
juste devant la maison des gens qui vont
nous emmener faire du rafting
proposeront des balades le plus grand
cours d'eau le plus grand autour d'eux
québec et moi c'est parti plus tard dans
chaîne trop de trucs cool dans ce voyage
de fou re bonjour je suis jean michel à
l'aise et je vais vous présenter kevin
qu'est ce qu'on va faire aujourd'hui on
va faire du rafting vous maintenez 35e
rap 6 au compteur la plus mauvaise
ces raccords on va aller dans une
rivière grande beaucoup d'eau ils
essaient de nous séduire il a dit aux
chaudes
c'est quoi les français qu'on est
frileux il a précisé chaude thabo cours
mais ouais c'est très bien aller retour
à montréal c'est parti on y va parce
qu'on a quand même dû signer un truc en
disant que si on meurt c'est pas grave
remarque est humain c'est pas grave on
n'est pas responsable et geste les plus
flippants anecdote ne plus penser pas le
sait pas le rafting
c'est une tique appris que dès qu'il
peut il ya une tique sur cinq qui peut
te filer une maladie et si tu fais rien
pendant 72 heures lance tu l'as pas vu
quoi et ben tu deviens invalides voilà
elle tente ait directement le système
neurologique et clément n'arrête pas de
phases et partout revoir mes mecs se
trouve ya eu six reviennent et x et hey
les mecs pays asiatiques à tpv occulte
de voilages ya pas trop de type sur la
rivière mais nous allons sur la rivière
tout de suite très bon me sens ok on
vient d'apprendre quelque chose
d'incroyable cette personne possède un
nom titi titi
alors là on va faire du raft mon gars
comme jamais ça va être fou
nous sommes arrivés au départ pour le
rafting l'eau est juste derrière nous
clément à sa grosse tête je veux pouvoir
me filmait moi je vous met ici ça allait
être comme ça le bateau et la [ __ ]
mais qu il est très très bon nous a
expliqué ce qu'il fallait faire ce que
tu allais pas faire j'ai juste trop
envie de voir que les mensualités du
bateau chez moi pour toi tu es un
connard
c'est parti
[Musique]
nous sommes sur le bateau il ya du monde
derrière qui va dégager de ce bateau en
premier les paris sont lancés
alors vous devriez au moins avoir une
pièce sur le dessus extérieur adacore
dégage dégage bien comme ça va c'est la
position pour dégager milliards
[Musique]
c'est le moment de la première rapide on
n'est pas mais ça veut dire 20 minutes
qu'on rame un mois mais bin jassim plus
du tout
[Musique]
m
cette coupe et rock hotel and others
hu
ok on va retourner dans les rapides
on va essayer de surfer cette fois
regarde ça c'est fou ça remue beaucoup
au niger
hu
c'est vrai que le mans t'as kiffé le mec
qui m'est tombé dessus steyaert de tout
emploi
[Musique]
pour les amis grotti jean-michel guide
nous a proposé de faire les rapides à la
nage s'en va te croire revivent noyade
imminente
une deuxième fois c'est très bien à
l'audio
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on est tu pars c'est parti
[Musique]
ok pas de héros de l'année
les amis c'est la fin de cette journée
et de cette deuxième vidéo canada
j'espère que vous a plu c'est calme si
t'es pas l'aimer comme d'habitude j'ai
aimé à dire cette phrase [ __ ] faut que
je change je vais dire tabarnak à la
place maintenant c'était une excellente
seconde journée beau d'être choqués
puisque c'est d'un coup la nuit alors
que juste avant on était encore sur le
bateau andré entre les deux un petit
barbecue avec philippe et kevin notre
guide et notre sauveteurs actuellement
on est dans un chalet ya même pas de
d'électricité vraiment pleine nature
c'est trop cool c'est ouf parce que
c'est la première fois que je rencontre
des gens comme serge et andré au parc
oméga et 24 heures après ben je dois
déjà les quitter pour aller rencontrer
d'autres et chez pas assez bizarre caj
manque de ouf c'est chouly des thèmes
ont même andré même mêmes demain là ils
vont nous manquer kevin des philippe
séveré aventures de ouf on est en train
de vider puis voilà on a deux tiers
finalement il ne reste plus que deux
jours sur 6 à vivre ça va être cool
j'espère que vous apprécierez la
prochaine vidéo aussi a les traits des
plaisanteries est vraiment temps de
dormir pour être en forme demain puisque
on a encore deux gros journée qui nous
attendent
allez bonne nuit ciao
[Musique]
où